peter zahan is one of the most well
respected american geopolitical analysts
he recently was doing a presentation
with the folks over at arkhanvest and of
course bitcoin came up as part of his
work and as many people know zahn he
thinks that bitcoin is an absolute
dumpster fire those are his words not
mine but what's so fascinating about it
is actually the thought process that
goes behind his conclusion so here's
part of the conversation where peter was
talking exactly about bitcoin and why he
thinks it is a dumpster fight
you think that bitcoin is quote unquote
a dumpster fire can you expand on that
point of view let me put the macro
economic background for why bitcoin is
happening now so the boomers right now
are in the most liberal investment
environment of their lives they're the
largest generation this world has ever
had so capital costs for the last couple
years are the lowest they've ever been
and in a couple years they're going to
be very very high because all that
boomer liquid capital is going to go
away it'll be locked into t-bills in
cash bitcoin is emerging in this
environment when money is free it's not
going to be here in a couple of years
it's
not a store of value it's not a method
of exchange it is not readily shiftable
into the real economy we've discovered
with the russian sanctions that it is
completely dependent upon the normal
financial system for access that means
it's vulnerable to anything the
government might do
it's already been banned in 10 of the
top 20 economies in the world and in
terms of productivity oh my god to
generate it you're talking about
something that if we ever get a carbon
tax has a negative value so yes there's
nothing about bitcoin that's here for
the long
now of course many people including
myself may disagree with some of the
thought process behind zahan's comments
but he went on to say even more and what
he ultimately concluded on was many of
the different use cases that people
highlight as to why bitcoin could be
valuable especially on a global stage
especially when there's geopolitical
risk uncertainty or chaos he ultimately
just decides that it's akin to money
laundering here listen exactly how he
describes it but if we're moving into a
world where trade breaks down what you
need for a global trade currency is
something that's large something that's
liquid and something where the
controlling body of the currency does
not regularly manipulate it so it can be
used with a degree of confidence that's
not bitcoin from the perspective of
someone in ukraine who is
fleeing the country and they can't get
money out of the atm because the atm's
literally on fire
and they get across the border and they
have access to their private wallet and
when they get across the border they can
then actually
expand economic resources that otherwise
they wouldn't have access to it's clear
that there's utility in that system why
wouldn't you just use a normal currency
for that scenario if you're going into a
system where there's a functional
society i don't see the utility i mean i
agree moving money out of a place
uh is something that bitcoin is used for
that's one of the reasons why a lot of
governments have banned it because it's
being used for smuggling the scenarios
where it is useful or not good enough
for it to be used regularly in any sort
of civilized system what you basically
just described is money laundering
now what's fascinating about this is
peter zeon he is one of the most well
respected geopolitical analysts in the
world and he continues to have very very
strong anti-bitcoin thought process now
whether he's right or wrong isn't for me
to decide or you ultimately my opinion
peter's opinion nor any of you watching
this your opinion as well it doesn't
matter the market will decide what
exactly is the true value of bitcoin
what i think is part of the missing part
of the conversation though is that
bitcoin continues to get adoption even
though so many different countries have
tried to ban it outlawed tax that are
regulated so many different individuals
around the world every single time they
get put into some sort of geopolitical
chaos or uncertainty they turn to
bitcoin helps them protect their wealth
helps them move it as seamlessly and
frictionless as possible and it also
gives them some sort of parachute a
lifeboat in these chaotic situations now
ultimately i don't know what's going to
end up happening but what i do know is
that every single fiat currency on the
planet
they have undisciplined rules they
change on a whim right now we're seeing
the european central bank literally say
hey we were very committed for eight or
nine years to negative interest rates
and a very specific monetary policy we
told the market these are what the rules
are going to be but now those rules are
changing and the ecb they're actually
not going to continue with the same
strategy they're now going to follow the
federal reserve they're going to make
capital more expensive and they're going
to raise that interest rate it's these
scenarios where bitcoin's programmatic
monetary policy the inability for any
individual or organization to actually
change bitcoin that highlights why
bitcoin may be valuable to so many
different people around the world now
again i don't know what's going to
happen but what i do know is on a
probability basis it's very likely that
bitcoin will continue to be adopted by
people around the world it doesn't
change no one can control it no one can
change the rules and that in today's
environment in all the global chaos
although geopolitical uncertainty and
all the undisciplined monetary and
fiscal policy probably is going to be
quite valuable